Buddha finds his enlightenment under a
tree it's not fluke that that's the case
that's his natural environment and he's
sitting in the Lotus here the Lotus
opens up and state this thing that
springs up from the depths he sits there
illuminated the same way he's got a halo
that's the Sun that stands for higher
consciousness and he's transcended by
accepting the fact that life is
suffering
he's transcended the limitations that
are part of mortality you see that
symbol there that's was tikka you see it
there it's reversed the Nazis reversed
it well think about that I mean they
weren't stupid as symbolism they're
symbols had meaning is what the swastika
were represented was what this
represents reversed
well that's a very bad idea this is the
thing that this this idea is what
enables people to transcend their
suffering and Buddha said well don't
don't be too attached to things and what
does that mean it doesn't mean deny the
world it might mean deny the world if
you're too in love with the material
like with material well-being let's say
then your pathway to transcendence and
meaning might be to abandon that because
it's it's constraining you it's making
you less than you could be but the
fundamental lesson the more fundamental
lesson that's underneath that is don't
let what you are stop you from being
what you could be right and so then the
question is well what do you identify
with do you identify with what you are
then you're tyrant do you identify with
with chaos because that's the opposite
of order say then you're nihilistic well
you don't identify with either of those
you know that they're both necessary you
know that you have to live with both of
them but you would you identify with the
capacity to continually transcend what
you are and then you seek out error
that's what humility is like I'm error
ridden it's like so I want to see I want
to put myself in the situation where I
can discover one of my errors hopefully
not in a way that's going to knock me
completely out of the game right I want
to I want to seek out a challenge I want
to find out where my limits are I want
to find out where there's not enough of
me yet
and I want to do it that in a way that's
engaging because you know you can wear
yourself out fighting dragons obviously
you can exhaust yourself completely and
that's not helpful you know what one of
the things I learned for example when I
was coaching when I was coaching lawyers
who these were people who had very
high-end careers and so they had an
infinite workload no matter how much
they worked flat-out there was always
way more work that they should do it's
very difficult thing to learn to manage
and so they were exhausting themselves
and I said well you know you have to
work less per day it's like well no
that's not happening I can't do that and
so with what I learned over time was
okay so this is what you have to do
every three months you have to block off
four days and go have a vacation you
have to plan that in advance so it's in
your calendar so that your secretary
doesn't book your time and then you need
that because you have to recuperate
enough so that you can work as hard as
you're going to work and of course they
were nervous about that and I said well
look we can we can calibrate this let's
keep track of your billable hours over
the next year and see if they increase
or decrease because I bet you if you
take more time off you'll actually have
more billable hours you'll actually have
your cake and eat it too you'll get to
have a vacation and you'll be more
productive and that inevitably that was
what happened and so that's a matter of
calibrating the game properly right you
want to play a game that you can play
the day but also one that you can play
next week and next month we're not
talking about you know your your career
this week we're talking about you having
a career that lasts 30 years that
doesn't kill you that doesn't make you
hate yourself or the job that doesn't
make you better that doesn't wear you to
a frazzle so we it has to be optimized
and so I think that you can in fact
decide to take on the load that's
optimally meaningful if you want and
then you get to have your cake and eat
it too you're on the pathway to
continual incremental improvement you
only have to burn off a feather at a
time instead of having the whole bloody
thing burst into flames but it's a
constant it's a constant source of
renewal and there's an idea that to be
renewed you have to drink the water of
life right that's that's an old
mythological idea and what's the water
the water of
like chaos is water water water is chaos
water is what washes away too much order
and to stay continually let's say
refreshed by the water of life is to
take on exactly the right amount of
chaos to make sure that your garden is
properly nourished and I think meaning
is actually the marker of that and and
as I said you know that I'm not I
wouldn't consider myself either naive or
a particularly optimistic person I don't
think I'm neither of those but this
isn't actually an idea this is one of
the only ideas that I've ever found that
I really believed to be rock-solid I
actually think that it's true and it's
very optimistic because it says you can
use your sense of meaning to calibrate
your progress through life it but
there's rules you have to aim at the
highest possible good that you can
conceive now in that subject update
because what the hell you know but you
start by aiming at the star you can see
rather than the dimmer one that you
can't yet perceive and then you decide
that you're going to do that honestly
right there's that that's a big decision
so the first decision I think in some
sense is the decision of love you're
going to decide that being is worthwhile
and that you're going to work for its
betterment and that's a decision that's
based on love and the second decision is
based on truth having made that decision
you're going to play a straight game
having made those two decisions I think
that you can allow your sense of meaning
to calibrate your pathway and then
what's so interesting is that you hit a
state that's as close to paradise as
you're going to hit right away because
being engaged like that is better to be
engaged in the solution of a complex
problem than not to have a problem at
all and that's that's no different than
saying it's better for there to be being
the non-being because being is a problem
and so if you want to have no problems
then you have no being and you could say
well-being is so miserable that maybe
that's the route we should take and fair
enough but maybe you can have your cake
and eat it too you can have the damn
problem it could be a problem worth
solving and you can be so engaged in
solving the problem that it justifies
the fact that the problem exists and
then you get then you get to have you
get to have the problem and the solution
at the same time and maybe that's better
than not having the problem
at all and I believe that because one of
the things I have seen and I've seen
this so interesting being so interesting
when I'd be lecturing to people
especially more recently and and this is
also manifested on mute by itself on
YouTube I'm talking to people a lot
about responsibility and it's young men
in particular that seem to be responding
to that and I think that's partly
because I think that young women in some
sense have their responsibility map
already laid out for them it's also less
voluntary in some sense for women
because they have more complicated
problems to solve in the first part of
their life right because they have to
get the family problem solved but
whatever
I've been talking very in a very
delineate 'add matter about
responsibility which is a strange thing
to sell to people but responsibility is
what gives you life meaning and so then
you might say well then take on ultimate
responsibility and what happens you have
an ultimately meaningful life then you
might say well if your life is
ultimately meaningful doesn't matter if
it's punctuated by tragedy or even
predicated on tragedy it's worth it and
I think that's true and in everything
I've seen indicates to me that's true
every time I get my clients to take on
more responsibility you know it and it
isn't an injunction you're a bad person
you should take on responsibility have
nothing to do with that you can define
the damn responsibility it isn't
something that that someone else should
impose on you it's not a matter of doing
what you should do in some abstract
manner it's not that it's the choice of
what game you're going to play and you
know you can play the game of the seeker
I would say and if you play that game
then everyone wins and it's the best
game you can play and so the the answer
in some sense to the tragedy of life to
the catastrophe of life to the fall is
to adopt the responsibility of mortality
that goes along with that and to play
that game maximally and paradoxically
it's in the willingness to do that that
the solution emerges